rassemblement ce matin sur l'esplanade
des invalides à paris
d'associations environnementales et
d'apiculteurs contre les néonicotinoïdes
objectif dénoncer la réintroduction de
ces pesticides interdits en 2016 car
considéré comme mortel pour les abeilles
577 abeilles en colère ont donc été
déployés ce qui correspond au nombre de
députés car partir d'aujourd'hui un
projet de loi est présenté à l'assemblée
nationale pour permettre aux producteurs
de betteraves sucrières d'obtenir une
dérogation sur l'utilisation de ces
pesticides
il ya de multiples études scientifiques
qui notamment du cnrs qui démontre le
danger
l'extrême toxicité de ces insecticides
qui sont parmi les plus puissants de
existants sur le marché
et c'est bien pour cela qu'ils avaient
été interdits en 2016 face aux effets
sur les pollinisateurs notamment et donc
les colonies d'abeilles c'est juste
intenable et inacceptable
on va une fois de plus seraient
empoisonnées l'environnement avec des
molécules d'une violence extrême qui ont
des durées de vie dans les sols qui sont
qui sont phénoménales et ça va
empoisonner une fois de plus l'air l'eau
le sol les combinaisons qui vont
s'opérer au niveau des sols sont
contrôlables et là on va une fois de
plus sacrifier nos abeilles au profit
solaire l'introduction des
néonicotinoïdes donc pour nous un pécule
torino c'est juste inacceptables et
inadmissibles